[موسيقى]
يخبرني الناس أن نيويورك يمكن أن تكون
أفضل مكان في العالم وأكثر
مكان اجتماعي في العالم ، ويمكنني أيضًا أن أكون أكثر
الأماكن وحدة في العالم ، كما أن
الهدف من نادي العشاء هذا هو جمع
الناس معًا
[موسيقى]
اسمي فينسينت وو وأنا معروف
بإدارة نادي عشاء يسمى السيد.
نادي عشاء جونز ، نعم ، سأجمع تلك
الإسكالوب في الطابق السفلي من
شقتي ، وسلة صغيرة من
الكراث ، بدأت عندما وصلت إلى هنا منذ حوالي ثلاث
سنوات ، لم أكن أعرف أي شخص
وأفتقد الالتقاء حول المطبخ
مع الأصدقاء  تناول الطعام وهكذا بدأت
مع معارف ، ثم أدى شيء ما
إلى شيء آخر وانفجر نوعًا ما ، فأنا
أفعل ذلك مرتين فقط في الشهر ، لكن
الطلب تجاوز عامين حتى الآن ،
وهذا ما يؤدي لتقريب الضيوف
لا يتعين عليهم الدفع مقابل القدوم  أنت تدفع ما
تشعر به في نهاية الليل
بناءً على مدى استمتاعهم
بالتجربة ومقدار ما يمكنهم
تحمله.
لست مدربًا رسميًا على الطهي
مع YouTube ، ربما يكون معلمي
كل شهر والسيد.  جونز ليس لديه قوائم طعام من
أي وقت مضى يوم السبت الماضي
بدأنا مع بعض بوراتا ثم كان
مصحوبًا بقطعتين من الجوز ومغطاة
برقائق جذور اللوتس المقلية ، ثم كان لدينا
أسقلوب كرودو أيضًا على
النكهات الآسيوية أيضًا ثم تناولنا الفطر
على  عيش الغراب على الفطر الذي يشبه
فطر الميتاكي الكبير المخبوز في
الفرن ، أحب القيام بذلك ، لقد
صنعت بالتأكيد أصدقاء منه ، ومن المؤكد أن الناس قد
كونوا صداقات مع بعضهم
البعض وكذلك المرة الأولى
التي تعرف فيها كما تعلم في العثور على أشخاص فقدوا منذ فترة طويلة
معًا  أعتقد أنها طريقة جيدة لمجرد
التوقف وإقناع الناس بالتواجد
أحيانًا مع أشخاص بدون هواتف
ومجرد التحدث والتعرف على شخص ما